a report this morning claims Russian
President Vladimir Putin gave direct
instructions to help elect Donald Trump
president according to a Washington Post
investigation former President Obama
received a secret CIA report in August
that report quote captured Putin
specific instructions on the operations
audacious objectives defeat or at least
damaged the Democratic nominee Hillary
Clinton Jeff Piquet's has the story of
how the former president struggled to
respond Geoff good morning good morning
CBS News confirmed last year that US
intelligence officials knew the Russian
government operation to interfere in the
u.s. election had been approved by
Vladimir Putin himself but they were
reluctant to reveal how much they knew
out of concern that sources and methods
could be compromised this morning The
Washington Post is reporting that US
intelligence agencies had sourcing deep
inside the Russian government capturing
Putin's direct instructions in the
operation the post also reports that
before he left office former President
Obama set in motion a secret program
that authorized the deployment of
implants in Russian networks digital
bombs that could be triggered in a
retaliatory cyber strike in the event of
Moscow aggression and that it would be
up to President Trump to decide to use
the capability CBS News confirmed that
Obama officials felt that their effort
to expel Russian diplomats in
retaliation was undermined by the
incoming administration determining
whether that is true is part of the
ongoing investigations CBS News has
confirmed that congressional
investigators are looking into whether
Trump campaign associates obtained
information from hacked voter databases
during the election so far there is no
evidence of that but it is a sign that
the congressional investigations are
expanding Noora great reporting Jeff
thank you so much